so i pronounce your name cairo yes sir
all right cairo tyro where'd you grow up
where you from
i grew up in south central los angeles
uh coming up i
experienced living in the shelter with
my mother and my little brother
we ended up staying on seventh and
alvarado with roaches rats and pigeons
i had roaches crawling my ears and on my
neck while i'm asleep
rats crawling by my feet and it'd be
right um
pigeon poop everywhere um going with my
dad he was a deadbeat but
he didn't really want to be in my life
much so what ended up happening was
he started touching me and trying to
molest me and whatnot
and i wasn't going for it so i tried to
learn self-defense self-defense
clearly didn't work because then his
friends started coming over and then
touching me and messing with me and
messing around with me
so almost uh
i was like seven in between seven and
nine
it was like my uh junior adolescent
life i was in between seven and nine
when that happened
then by the time i turned 13 i was
almost turned out i didn't
really want to be bothered with girls
like that but i wasn't
i wasn't turned on the men either i just
just wanted to be left alone i was like
asexual at that point and like guys or
girls i just wanted to be myself
by the time i hit age 13 i started
selling drugs because i got into a world
that i wasn't ready for but
i thought i was ready for it because i
seen everybody else making good money i
wanted to make good money too
so i started selling marijuana at first
then by the time i hit 15
i started smoking crystal meth uh
started
snorting cocaine i tried pcp
uh the little shrimp sticks i didn't
tried um
dmt didn't like it much then did acid
didn't did shrooms everything but crack
okay and the
dragon choice is probably would be like
defending all heroin and downers because
it made me not think about
what happened to me that's all i was
coming up so
what are you using today uh faint no
finna i was a
two and a half year heroin addict i was
addicted to china white
but i my the way my hustle is i was able
to support my habit
every day i was spending two three
hundred a day on on
on fentanyl or heroin just to get
certain little childhood [ __ ] off my
mind
and it's like i at the time growing up i
wasn't thinking about what the drugs
would do to me as i got older
so by the time i hit 17 i was fully
turned out on drugs
i was smoked out i smoked just about
anything
dipped cigarettes uh crystal if i got my
hands on it
hard time alcoholic
it just helped me forget about the the
childhood
trauma so then i went to trauma centers
when i was 16
because i became uh
anxious so i get mad about thinking
about the past or
a guy would come at me and i wouldn't
like how he came at me so then i just go
in the bathroom and start cutting myself
and i get a fat kitchen knife with the
ridges on and just started slicing my
arm like open until i seen
blood come out and gush and once the
blood started
dripping then i felt the rest and i'm
like all right i gotta stop
so i stopped i stopped and then i
started
i tried shooting a couple of times i
shot her black tar heroin
i didn't like to hide so i started
smoking it and then
i shot crystal a couple times and i
didn't like how my arms were starting to
look so i stopped shooting crystal and i
started smoking it
and i started selling crystal selling
pcp
selling marijuana and it didn't help my
life but it helped me with my
with the trauma that i was enduring at
the time so
to get away from all the trauma in total
i just started using drugs and got fully
turned out by drugs
and growing up in south central growing
up in south central drugs is everywhere
yeah
yeah uh when i was 14 i got put on black
pea stones
i was third i was 12 13 i already stayed
in the jungles
i was affiliated because i had family
that were in there in the game yes sir
black pistons is a blood gang uh it
stands for
blood that's for uh brotherly love
order oppression and depression
so basically what it what it was was
when i got put on it was a brotherhood i
didn't i was homeless
i was out in the streets strung out
family didn't want to
have nothing to do with me i kept asking
for money pretty often
i knew they were getting tired of it i
kept losing phones
i kept losing valuable [ __ ] every time i
my parents go give me clothes or go
shopping i sell the clothes just to get
my fix
so it got rough for me at a point and
after a while i just got tired of it so
i started selling more drugs but i
started selling drugs for
for my hood so being a blood gang member
when you first get put on you feel me
initiation is
you get packed out four to you know five
to six
people it's generally five minutes and
then
after that you hop in the car you go
slide so i had to go slide on
a couple i'm not gonna mention all of it
but i
i did a little i do some work put in
work for the set i'm green
i'm good and ain't nowhere in l.a or
it ain't nowhere in the world i can't go
they know where i'm scared to go people
know me they respect me
but it's just coming up that's all i
knew i seen other people getting money
that way
i knew people that were getting money
that way it's like how come i can't get
money that way
so i used that as a form to support my
hustle
like an anchor so the gang was my anchor
but it also weighed me down because
i kept being in and out of jail first
charge was
uh aggravated assault then i got
stronger armed robbery
then i got auto theft i was able to
clear it
but you feel me trying to be 16 17 and
now i'm already homeless emancipated
what not
and i'm in the streets trying to get a
job when they background check me i
wasn't able to get a job at all they
didn't trust me around money they didn't
trust me around product
so it's like i'm not going to be a
janitor i'm not cleaning up after
anybody i already got to clean up after
myself and take care of myself
so it just got worse so you finished
high school uh
no i dropped out in
the uh i dropped out my senior year i
got a class selling we don't care we
xanax and codeine on campus
so since i was distributing narcotics on
campus i got kicked out for that
i also had to come since i went to
school in the [ __ ] neighborhood and i
was like
one of the only few like real bloods
that went to the school i had to come to
school with a gun every day it was a
couple of times where
i didn't have to i didn't really got out
of school and this is already like 40 to
60
40 to 100 crips outside and i got a good
but my my gun don't got it i don't got
enough bullets for 42 or 60 people
so it's like am i gonna fight or am i
gonna run
i wasn't gonna run so i started fighting
and once i
started getting into fights i started
liking the adrenaline rush of hurting
and hitting people so then what i do is
i get drunk and i get hot
and i talk to people crazy just to test
people and
it got worse to a point where one guy
actually stabbed me
and he stabbed me in my
in my spinal cord and i wasn't able to
walk for seven months
so at age 18 i wasn't
able to walk for at least the first
eight to 12 months of the year i had to
learn how to walk again
so i got the surgery i was
lucky and fortunate to be young so i was
able to heal fast and regenerate
my body but at the same time it crippled
me because it's like
no i can't really get a job i'm not
trusted around product or money
you feel me i'm labeled as a thief
klepto um
i had a [ __ ] up childhood i was
molested and touched
you feel me so that's traumatizing as i
got older guys started looking at me
like
they looked at me like as if how a guy
looks at a
cute female so they're looking at me
like oh he's a cute guy let me try
something with him
so then one guy tried to peer pressure
me into smoking crack cocaine told him i
didn't do it
he bought me some opiates and then he
molested me in his apartment he wouldn't
let me out put the chain on the door put
a gun on me and said if i didn't do it
he was gonna blow my brains up so i did
it so i keep my life
that happened a couple of times people
told me they give me money just for
helping them out
i'm thinking they actually need help
with something you know they just trying
to have sex they high off crack cocaine
they're high off meth at the same time
they get horny
so when they get horny off that they
don't care if it's a guy or a girl
you feel me or both they don't care if
you're homeless clean what so
i got caught up in that circle because i
was in the streets people know i needed
help they know i needed money
i got to have it so i got to support my
habit so
while supporting my habit and being in
the streets and
being in the game killing people going
back to jail for burglaries and
robberies and
assault charges i was able to get
everything expunged
i could get a job now the only thing
that's stopping me is my childhood
trauma
i don't want to work anywhere around
guys if i'm in the
facility and it's not more than at least
six to eight women i don't want to even
work there if there's too many guys
i feel like what happened to me growing
up will happen again
i'll get touched or somebody to try me
and i'll be at work and i'll lose my job
because i'll have to defend myself
the job's not going to see it that way
they're going to like their hair longer
they got
they got seniority you feel me so it's
like
growing up that way it's like you
traumatize
it's like it breaks you you get older
and older and just like
damn like i wasted a lot of time
you're only 22. i'm only 22. do you have
do you have hope of a better life for
you
i do i'm trying to get off drugs right
now but i don't want to go to rehab
because i feel like i'm gonna go to
rehab they're gonna help me out
everybody that i know like family member
homies
and whatnot the drugs are still gonna be
there i'm gonna still know where to get
them the trauma's still gonna be there
the trauma's still gonna be there
and the drugs are still gonna be there
so it's like i'm gonna get out of rehab
it's gonna help with the drugs and stuff
to help me get a job and get out of
rehab
and then i'm gonna go back to wanting to
get hard because that's what i know i've
been hustling get high
go to sleep hustle get hard try to
forget
hustle get high try to get by that's
literally what i do i get high to get by
the trauma and to try to forget about
some of the things i didn't have to do
to people
just to get my name over what's what's
the most you don't need to be
specific but what's what's the most
extreme thing you've done or what
regrets do you have
regrets i have um
if anything it'd be it'd probably be the
murders
because honestly i didn't killed more
than five people
and like i didn't kill people in traffic
driving i didn't kill people who
break into their house or and it's a
it's a
stronghold strong armed robbery at that
point and then there's burglary and
breaking and entering so that's already
three sentences right there
on top of the felony because i'm
trespassing so that's four sentences
uh biggest regret would probably be
doing drugs
and killing as many people my color that
i had to kill
it wasn't that i wanted to but it's
you're from the gang you didn't already
got your [ __ ]
you put on ribs broken everything i'm on
the block i'm in the hood
almost every day hanging out chilling
kicking it or whatever
so it's like at that point i was like
[ __ ] it i'm gonna have to change
something i'm gonna have to start off
doing something new
something better for myself started
listening to rap music
probably at like 12 13 and rap music
influenced me to do drugs as well
because a lot of the rappers
that are in my race all they talk about
is drugs and all they talk about is
getting these nice cars and nice jewelry
and you feel me having these
big houses and when i saw i wanted that
lifestyle so i
tried to start selling code and i got
stabbed
several times got stabbed in this
stomach twice
and i got stabbed in both my thighs and
what the person tried to do was they
tried to [ __ ] me so i couldn't walk
i've also been tortured by the cartel
i've had
uh mana sara chuches uh thresei members
tied me up to a chair poured water on my
on my head and gagged me
and i couldn't breathe i thought i was
gonna die i thought they were really
going to cut my head off they had
chainsaws ready
they had acid ready that's probably the
scariest thing
selling drugs and getting involved with
the cartel that's probably the scariest
and the only regret i got messing with
the cartel
can you can you even imagine growing up
you know with a with a dad very
different from yours who is supportive
and a good role model for you um and
into in
maybe a more a wealthier neighborhood uh
yeah that also played a part um
if i was in a more wheelchair
neighborhood i probably wouldn't have
been on the drugs that i was on
because then what they're in their
neighborhoods they generally do pure
drugs
so then i'd have been doing pure
fentanyl pure
uh china white that's not saying i've
been exposed to the gangs and drugs i
wouldn't have been exposed to the
to the gangs at least i'd have been
exposed to the judge because rich people
do drugs too
it's just how they doing they don't
look hard they don't look smoked out
they do enough drugs to
be satisfied so i started doing using
cocaine a lot more
so i noticed cocaine helped me with
opiate with
uh my opiate addiction i've been stuck
on opiates since i was 16
22. i've been in the office for six
years straight it started off with
um uh hydrocodone
narco and then i moved up to percocet
then i started
popping narcos and percocets at the same
time then
it didn't get me hot so then i do xanax
narco percocet codeine promethazine
and crush all of it i put it in one soda
poured three four lines with some
coating and promething and soda
drink it and i'd be so high and out of
this world that i wouldn't even think
about
that my childhood trauma until somebody
comes and brings it up
or i'm on the bus and it's five six
[ __ ] at the back door
and it's a dude damn near my balls and
another [ __ ] on my eyes like
it's just uncomfortable i've already
been touched and [ __ ] so it's like
i don't want nobody that close to me my
personal space is everything to me
have you ever talked to your dad uh i
talked to him on occasion
me and my dad don't have a good
relationship due to my childhood trauma
yeah
so i don't even really try to mess with
him uh i've tried to talk to him about
it he denies everything denied
everything like so at one point nothing
to take him to court
i didn't even feel like taking him to
court cause i was like if he's gonna
deny everything and
it happened so long ago they can't even
dna test to see
or prove if he really actually did it or
if i'm actually telling the truth
to his the judge thought i was trying to
get money
so i talked to a lawyer and everything
and they said they will be able to
take my case but i'd have to pay for it
i'm staying on the streets i'm selling
drugs and i'm doing drugs
i don't have money to pay for that
lawyer so it's like if i win they get
paid regardless but if i lose
then i'm losing i'm being dead i didn't
want to be in debt then people
my dad didn't stole my social security
card started getting credit cards in my
name
bill's in my name by the time i hit 18
my credit was [ __ ]
so it's like i didn't have people who do
my edds my dad did it
his girlfriend did it they stole 25 000
from me and they know i'm out here i'm
struggling i don't got money like that
but they didn't give a [ __ ] as long as
they was good they were straight
they got the money they got the social
they got many pictures of me
that's nothing for them they got copies
of my id
my dad stole my birth certificate my
real birth certificate from my mother
she ended up taking it back and she
after that just went downhill my parents
weren't ever together
in the first place they were together
when they had me my mom tried to get my
dad to be in my life he didn't want to
be there
so i just don't talk to my dad's side
because of the trauma that i endured and
they let it happen how's your
relationship with your mom
um my relationship with my mom is great
my mom knows i do drugs my mom knows
that
i'm out here in the streets she doesn't
know i had to sell my ass or
you feel me that i've been touched or
molested because she works in the
hospital so
that's certain things i just haven't
told her but i'm
reluctant to never have caught hiv or
aids or hepatitis or
chlamydia i've never had a std i've
never had a
uh humane
immune virus i've never had aids i've
never had any type of
disease anything from having sex or
unprotected sex with people
i've almost had two kids one of my
females aborted
one kid so we broke up because i wanted
the baby but
i wasn't in the right place to take care
of the kid
i didn't want to just have everything
follow her then her dad got on me was
like oh well if you have a baby with my
daughter you're gonna have to marry her
i'm young i didn't want to get married i
don't believe in marriage it's like i'm
young i want to have as many girlfriends
as i want
so i feel like i should be able to do
that like
you could be with a girl and you can
marry her i don't that's not going to
stop her from running off and sneaking
behind your back to have sex with
somebody else
and then you end up with a disease or
something and she's lying to you telling
you that
you feel me she's only having sex with
you and then you end up with something
and you know she's the only person
you're having sex with but you don't
know what she's doing she has a whole
car
i'm in the streets walking taking the
bus everywhere to me it just wasn't
worth it
i had to get out the relationship with
the next girlfriend money hungry
i ended up going to jail for her when uh
some old guy assaulted her
in front of me so i didn't really care
how old he was i just
instinct i immediately just sucked them
bro so they ended up calling her family
after they busted my front and back
windshield i was beating with a metal
baseball bat
um they tried to cut my head open with a
box cutter
and before the police came they choked
me to the point where i could
where i was losing air i couldn't
breathe much they almost crushed my
larynx
and the ambulance had to come when the
ambulance came they said i was fine
and i ended up in increase so i'm
thinking like why am i in handcuffs and
he's not in handcuffs
then they actually arrested the old guy
but then letting him out and i was on
fifty thousand dollar bill i didn't have
fifty thousand dollars let alone five
just to get out
so i ended up putting my mom through
extra stress and extra drama because
it's not like i call my dad and ask him
for it
so i had my mom ended up paying the
whole 50 grand now i'm in a home my mom
at least
quarter to half a million dollars just
off of
getting me out of jail she's the only
person that'll build me up
and uh what i always tell myself is like
if i hit the lottery or i ever
get rich or big one day i'll make sure
my mom don't ever have to work again
like because she was there for me so
since she had me that was looking like
an anchor and support
a support column i was able to talk to
her about anything she doesn't like me
doing drugs
but she sees why i do drugs she her
biggest fear is
because she's getting married next month
which i'm proud of her for so i will
have a father figure
but at the end of the day she's moving
out of state and i can't go so i'm stuck
here and i'm already
why can't you go not having my place um
i chose to stay in california i didn't
want to go to texas i don't want to have
to start a new life out there
i'm already good and settled in
california los angeles to be exact
i'm good like as far as it comes to
drugs making money boosting what not
you're homeless right now
yes sir um being homeless wasn't even
it wasn't easy either sleeping on
concrete sleeping on the street
coming from a shelter when you're young
being homeless like as you get older
just makes the trauma even worse because
then it's like
you're thinking about like damn what if
i'm sleeping somebody touches me or
what if i'm sleeping somebody stabs me
or kills me like just because
what if i'm sleeping somebody said i did
something i didn't do i'm going to jail
for
false accusation i'm going to jail for
being affiliated i could be in the car
with four or five dudes
and we literally could just be smoking
chilling hanging out the players
literally will come pull us over
everybody handcuffs
once they see my record then they get
four or five more officers to come out
then it's like damn now i'm thinking i'm
going to go to jail
because me and my homies just chilling
and stuff i've been gifted to never be
on parole or probation
so every time i did go to jail either i
bailed out
after a week or two or after i seen the
judge they let me out on good behavior
or whatnot
so i was blessed to get out on good
behavior but at the same time it's like
i should have never had to really endure
any of that
but i blame myself i needed structure i
needed
a father figure or at least a man in my
life
like to just be there for me to give me
an anchor
of support and i didn't have that well i
had that with my grandfather but it's
not the same
when you feel me you're a parent isn't
do you feel me that supportive there
anyone touching you
and traumatizing you is kind of like
scary
this is like you feel like the cards
were stacked against you
yeah in your life totally um
drugs gangs drugs women
making sure i don't die my mom's biggest
regret is
she feels like she's gonna have to come
back from texas and bury me
but i feel like i'm not gonna go that
far with the drugs to the point where
i'll kill myself
if i get too high then i'll just narcan
myself i'll just be pissed the [ __ ] off
but
i don't ever when i buy drugs i don't
ever do all my jokes because i also got
to think about
i just spent money on this so i have to
make more money
and then i boost so i gotta think i'm
risking my freedom
to go steal something that's not even
worth my time let alone
money you feel me so it's like
i'm it's a lot of cars like just
against me right now it's like i don't
have the structure
of a father figure never had one i had
people that tried but
this is hard growing up being a boy and
you feel me your mom
is the structure your mom is the
the anchor and you feel me it's only so
much a female could teach you a female
can't teach you how to be a man
like so i had to teach myself so that's
literally what the gangs helped me with
the games helped me teach me how to be a
man they
my mom taught me manners and whatnot the
gang taught me
how to hustle how to get respect because
respect is
earn not giving you give everybody
respect and they don't give it back then
it's like
they're playing you at that point so i
didn't want to get played
i didn't want to feel betrayed i didn't
want to feel [ __ ] over anything so
if i was in the car with a bunch of my
homies if something did happen the
police did come
i'm not going to go to jail for that i'm
not taking the blame for nobody else's
guns or drugs
now whatever is on me and they find me
with that's possession
of you for me illegal narcotics but it's
personal use
but the way that i picked up the
narcotics and the bags and
whatnot that i had them in looked like i
was selling so i'd always get a
possession charge like oh
possession of phenol possession of
heroin i'm not doing cut drugs i'm doing
pure dress
pure cocaine pure china pure heroin
which is the china white
and uh pure fentanyl but it's carphone
though
so my biggest regret is doing the
opiates because i'm really
hooked on opiates so when i do pop pills
or i do sip coding
i do anything any type of object female
heroin
you feel me uh heroin and liquid form
which would be the coding i always feel
like i'm gonna overdose
but always keep narcan on me just in
case to save myself because
i'm by myself so if i'm homeless
like i'm already homeless but like
sleeping
situation hey for example i didn't have
a place to sleep for at least a good
six months one of my family my cousins
kicked me out because
uh one of the females that uh i was
messing around with
just he decided to mess around with her
to try to make me jealous and mad
which i look he was mad because she
didn't tell me and he didn't tell me
they tried to cover it up and hide it
from me
so when i found out it made me mad so
unfortunately for her
it cost her her life she died february
2nd 2021
she's been my childhood best friend
since probably middle school probably
before that we grew up together so it
hurt me
that she decided to do some mischievous
[ __ ] to
like get up under my skin and now it
costed her her life and now she's not
here how did she die
uh fentanyl overdose she
we we had uh started smoking
oxycodone 30s we put them on the foil
and smoking
my uh one of my cousins showed us how to
do it because we were smoking heroin
well i was smoking heroin i don't know
what she was doing but i was smoking
heroin so
we started putting oxys on the foil and
i got a tolerance now so it's like uh
spending
300 maybe 600 a day spending
two three thousand a week just on pills
so
what happened to her was somebody gave
her a bad batch she popped them because
she didn't want to smoke them at home
she popped them
thought she was in the nod off and go to
sleep she was high i guess
her people came to get her and
unresponsible
she didn't have narcan so she just died
oh dude and i look you blame my cousin
for that but i blame myself for that
because i introduced you to my cousin
but i blame her for that because it's
like
if you would have just been still
[ __ ] with me or mess around with me
or the guy that you was messing with
first
it wouldn't cost you your life you'd
still be here but at the same time
it's just a lesson learned like drugs
ain't nothing to play with
like you could get a bad batch and most
drug dealers out here don't care
like when it comes to the drug world
drug dealers don't care they'll sell you
rap poison
and tell you that it's fit though and
you smoke it thinking
oh yeah i'm high now and get a weird
heart and then you'll be wondering why
your body is feeling
weak and wow wow your skin is
deteriorating or your hands and nails
get septic or your teeth fall out and
whatnot
biggest mistake probably smoking drugs
because it is
it has rotted a lot of my teeth so now
when i actually do get money or i do get
up there
eventually i'm gonna have to get a whole
new girl i'm gonna have to buy all new
teeth
so i'm gonna end up being probably 25
with a whole mouthful of fake teeth
drugs and soda tyra what's uh what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
most important lesson i learned is skin
folk and can folk
just because we're the same race and we
we got the same blood flowing through
our skin don't mean we found
family will set you up first family will
be the first people to take any
everything from they'll clean you draw
if they if they have to
really that's like you try if it comes
down to it
uh biggest lesson i learned besides that
would be um don't trust
everybody like that's where i messed up
at if i don't have product in my hand or
you didn't give me anything to sell or
i haven't got anything for myself to
sell then
i can't give you product and i haven't
seen cash yet because then at that point
you're finessing me
now i've given a lot of people product
and a lot of people in these streets owe
me money
but i didn't just turn to other chick
and i was like [ __ ] it
that's on me like i was supposed to get
the money first and that's where i
[ __ ] up
i'm giving people product giving them
the benefit of the doubt
and they're screwing me in the back and
not the way i want to be screwed like
because i wouldn't want to be screwed in
the back but you feel me it's just
that's just how it is that's the lesson
i have to learn if i'm
hustling and i'm boosting i'm selling
drugs and whatnot you can't front nobody
anything until money is presented
because then they put me in the hole
with one plug also a whole thousand in
the hole
and i still owe my 2-300 now and i still
haven't paid it
and i make 2-3 grand a week off boosting
so it's like
my priorities it's just getting high and
making sure i got a place to sleep
i hate when i gotta wear the same
clothes but it's been times
where i haven't been in the streets and
really don't have no contact with my
family so
i really gotta wear the same clothes for
two or three weeks maybe a month don't
shower for
a whole six to eight weeks it breaks my
pride down
because i'm thinking about how do i
smell how do i look
but everybody else is just like yeah
bomb he smoked out
disney's net he owned drugs he had a
drug addict
if you give him money he can spend it on
the fix but everybody can't think like
that because every time i get money i
don't always buy drugs i buy food i buy
clothes
get a little backpack little jewelry
whatever like
i spend my money on things that if i
ever am in the fixa
it starts raining or something at least
i got a jacket to
protect me from the rain i stay warm i'm
not wet
if i need a place to sleep i know a
couple of people that stay in apartments
i'll sleep in their steroid i'll go to
the third floor about a roof
lay out my little cover or whatever or
put it on my jacket with another shirt
or whatever
put a little sheet or something on the
floor so i'm not laying on the floor and
i'll sleep in the
park mr airway and i've been doing that
for the last two or three months
so when i came downtown and i found out
one of my boys had a tent
i just started helping him sell fennel
and
uh crystal and crack out of his tent but
at the same time it's like that's not
the lifestyle
i chose when i was in school and my
teachers used to ask me what i wanted to
be
i'm not gonna lie i kept it 100 i want
to be a drug dealer i want to make fast
money and i want to be on top
like i used to hear about pablo escobar
and
people like that uh griselda blanco you
feel me like i
wanted to be on top i wanted to have
money even if i did get involved with
dakar too
my biggest regret is getting involved
with the cartel
and not making as much money as i see on
tv
when i watch tv and i watch certain
shows i'm seeing them make
thousands hundreds of thousands out one
time 50k
to a half a million in gold
kilos of coke all that so i wanted to be
a part of that lifestyle and when i
realized that
i'm getting in too deep then that's when
i wanted out
the cartel you can't just run out they
got to let you up
so that's really where i [ __ ] up i had
to like change my name get an alias
right now i'm growing dreads out i had
to change the way i looked
because i had the cartel on me wanting
to kill me
but now i didn't talk to him i didn't
work things out you female oh nobody i'm
good
anytime i ever need to be a runner again
you feel me i'm good i'm sad i'm
straight
but other than that that's a segment of
my life
all right cairo thanks so much for
sharing your story thank you i
appreciate you the best of luck
thanks no problem
you